[Music]
lissa coils here with GameSpot I am here
at e3 2014 and I have sneaked into the
Bethesda booth everything is so behind
closed doors as you can see up here we
can't even show anything on the screens
that's how close doors it is but up
there
the Elder Scrolls online the evil within
people are behind those doors witnessing
these games more than Oh 2 9 battle cry
beautiful big posters and I definitely
wanted to show you some of these awesome
statues of some of the characters look
at how detailed look at how detailed
this is I wish I'm going to Stan's here
I have a microphone inside of a giant
sword it is not as effective
it's got arrows here in these bags
pretty stellar skulls I just I love the
creativity that goes into these booths
see if that's another aspect of e3 that
you just don't experience at home
unfortunately it looks cool but then
when you're actually in the flesh seeing
it it's beautiful alright let's come to
this one okay
this guy's this is this is quite this is
quite a sword this is like final fantasy
levels of giant sword awesome again very
very detailed very cool I love just the
just the little touches I mean this is
inside the booth not not a lot of gaming
going on inside here but yet they still
you know decorate it really cool I wish
I could show you things on the screen
but the evil within I've been told a
little bit about this game I really
don't know that much about it but it is
apparently really terrifying I'm not
good with scary games but I get done
there's this cool screen where you can
like take your picture and put your face
in it and get your face covered in
barbed wire so hopefully I don't know if
there's like a line is there a line no
no okay so we'll see if we can like kick
these guys out like weird games but let
us in tonight can I do this can I try
this okay what is that what is it what
is this basically the evil within you're
going to create your own cover for that
so I'll let you I love her for the game
oh my gosh okay alright okay I'll get my
mic for another way
[Music]
it'll count our cream and make like the
serious face
[Music]
my face was out of the thing is that
gonna be a problem it was like perfect
fire I look very bright why would I do
this to myself why would I put barbed
wire around my face
[Music]
have you played any of the game I have
not I have not touched it yet
unfortunately gamer I am a gamer but I'm
on a photobooth duty so I'm like
crossing my fingers cuz I keep watching
this and I want a place so bad I'm like
I'm itching and everyone's walking and
behind me too and I'm like everything's
behind closed doors
I hear screams I'm out here and I hear
like little screams or things like that
and I mean it's gonna be a sick game I'm
gonna do this kit I can't do the scary
games like dead space like those cups so
I can't I can't do yeah yeah oh sure
how did I do here you did amazing now
you'll get to see the finished product
so touch here to continue and that is
your cover wow that's pretty horrific
that's a pretty good cover you can send
it to yourself if you want you can use
that as like my acting head shot maybe
or to my mom
facebook profile picture perfect mom
this is what I'm up to
it's great well thank you thank you for
showing me this I don't I don't need to
have it but it might get me nightmares
so there you go cool up thank you got a
cool little face barbed wire I just
became the cover of the evil within
so again which I can show you more
everything is behind closer is here a
Bethesda but be sure to tweet me your
thoughts on the evil within I want to
know more about this game I want to know
what the appeal is tweet me Ally's voice
and use the hashtag GameSpot III see you
later
[Music]